DAVID EHRLICH: I know that this
is not necessarily a true
story, but it is based on your
personal experiences working
at a short term home.
Can you talk a little
bit about when--
what about your experience
there you
really wanted to convey?
And when in the process--
was it as soon as you left the
job there that you knew you
needed to make a movie
about this?
DUSTIN CRETTON: No, when I was
working there, I wasn't really
able to think beyond that day
and trying to survive that
day, and trying to survive that
week, trying to get over
the fact that I was constantly
terrified and constantly
wanting to quit.
But over the course of those
two years, it was a very
impacting experience for me.
And it stuck with me all the
way through college, or
through my masters
program in film.
And so it was about three years
later when I had the
assignment of doing
a thesis film.
I went back through my old
journals that I'd written
during my time when I
was working there.
And I think enough time had
passed at that point that I
was able to organize some of
those thoughts into a story,
which was a short
film initially.
That was my thesis.
And then later, that transformed
in the feature.
DAVID EHRLICH: When you went
to transform the short, did
you just knock it all over
and start from scratch?
Or did you organically build
it from there with similar
characters?
DUSTIN CRETTON: I had to knock
it over because I initially
tried to expand it from the
short film and use all the
same characters.
But it just felt boring.
I felt like I was re-doing the
same thing, and not sure it
was initially meant to be
turned into a feature.
So as soon as I changed the main
character from a male to
a female protagonist,
everything--
the whole world changed.
Cool socks, by the way.
DAVID EHRLICH: Oh, geez.
I don't think that I remembered
that I was going to
be doing anything in public
today when I put these on.
DUSTIN CRETTON: I love
those socks.
DAVID EHRLICH: So now, a
question for Miss Larson.
I think it's sort of an obvious
question, but one well
worth asking because the
performances are so--
there's an intimacy that's
fostered between you and the
other characters and it seems
so lived in the entire
performance.
And so I guess I'm just
wondering what sort of
preparation you did, who you
may have spoken with
beforehand to really get
into that world?
BRIE LARSON: Yeah, there's a
few different aspects that
needed to be understood
and explored
before we started shooting.
One is all of the subtext that's
throughout the film,
which is a lot fueled
by her past.
So I had to think about that,
create that, which involved
also sitting down with John.
And we went to dinner.
And Dustin gave us these little
conversation starters
that got us talking about our
childhoods, and fears of being
a parent, and then specifics
about our relationship.
And then, the other aspect
of it was her job.
And I shadowed at a facility,
as well as just openly spoke
with some people that have
Grace's job, and then sat down
with each one of the kids and
talked with them a little bit
about what information I would
know about them to understand
better how Grace would relate
with them, how she would--
what her expectations were of
each one of them, and their
sensitivities.
And all of those combined, and
then Norwegian black metal to
be able to listen to before
starting each scene kind of
informed the whole thing.
DAVID EHRLICH: New age,
is that what you said?
BRIE LARSON: No, Norwegian
black metal.
DAVID EHRLICH: Ah, I see.
Ah, that makes sense.
New age would also make sense.
JOHN GALLAGHER: New
age would be cool.
DAVID EHRLICH: And a question
for both of the actors here.
There's such a performative
quality about the job, as it's
required, not as actors but
to work as counselors.
Here, I think as it's seen very
clearly in the movie,
have to put on masks to
go to work every day.
And Rami's character is without
the mask, hasn't built
that mask for himself yet.
And so as actors, was that
something that helped you get
into the role, understanding
what that's like to always
feel like you're performing?
DUSTIN CRETTON: What a
great observation.
DAVID EHRLICH: It's the socks.
JOHN GALLAGHER: I think for my
character, that is almost
maybe slightly more obvious
because he uses humor as a
kind of tactic, a way to
distract and deflect and
comfort the kids in a way that
I think was fascinating.
Because it's the idea of how
can you be a really good
friend to these kids, but also
stay a disciplinarian and stay
trustworthy?
And there's something about
coming to their level and
goofing around with them and
joking around with them that
disarms them in a way.
But then also, when the tables
turn, you then have their
trust in a way.
So that when it comes time to
crack the whip a little bit,
if you need to raise your voice
or restrain someone
that's freaking out, you're
able to do that little
balancing act.
That was something that I
shadowed at the same facility
that Brie did.
And that was something that I
saw was very prevalent there
was keeping things light.
Not in a way that's
disrespectful, but just kind
of joking and keeping a light
air throughout the day to try
and just get through
the day without
any tantrums or anything.
DUSTIN CRETTON: I think it's
really cool that you bring
that up because I was
just talking about
this earlier today.
One of my supervisors was a
female who, when I talked to
her or hung out with her outside
of the walls of that
place, she had a very
small frame.
And her voice was very quiet.
She was some kind of
shy personality.
And when she went through the
gates to be a supervisor for
this place, I could literally
see her stand outside and take
a breath and put on this thing,
this personality, this
somewhat fictional-- but
it is a part of her.
But she puts on this armor.
And when she would walk into
that place, she was a bad ass.
And the kids respected her.
She respected them.
And she was a really incredible
supervisor and a
wonderful person to work for.
So that was a cool
observation.
DAVID EHRLICH: Yeah, especially
in context of
Grace's character and
that badass-ness.
After a long summer of
superheroes, it's nice to see
something a little bit more
relatable in that vein.
BRIE LARSON: The
real superhero.
DAVID EHRLICH: Exactly.
And to that end, were
there any points--
because there's a certain social
responsibility that you
guys may have felt while making
this that you wanted to
represent these kids in a way
that was honest and accurate,
and maybe help people in their
situations realize that family
is a fluid idea, and that
there's always a
chance to have one.
And I wonder, was there any
point in crafting the drama
and attending to the needs of
every scene that you felt that
what you wanted to do as
a writer or as an actor
interfered with a greater
responsibility to telling this
accurately?
DUSTIN CRETTON: All these
interesting questions!
BRIE LARSON: I think it wasn't
necessarily specifically about
the social issue of it.
But any time I've found that I'm
playing a character, and
especially someone that you
spend a lot of time with, like
I had to with Grace, and you're
playing somebody who's
really struggling, you so badly
at a certain point want
to be above them and help them
and do what I would want her
to do, but not what
she actually does.
And it becomes painful as the
vessel of her to continue to
throw yourself into a situation
knowing that it's
going to be painful, knowing
that it's counterproductive to
what is actually
good for them.
Because you care about
them and love them.
And there's been many
times where--
not during this film, but
another film in particular--
where I remember arguing for
a very long time with the
director about the ending.
Like, my character's final scene
and the outcome of it,
and I argued for a long time.
And he finally said, you
have to let this go.
This has nothing
to do with you.
You can't do what she wants.
You can't do what you
want for her.
It has to be what she wants.
I was like, aw!
It's hard because you were
playing somebody.
And you're inside them.
But then, you also have this
weird perspective of being
almost outside of my body and
away from this character.
And it's so important.
And it's a strange balance to
play to just allow it to be
what she's going to be doing.
DAVID EHRLICH: Mr. Gallagher,
not to type cast you as a nice
guy, but I think certainly the
rules I've seen you in
recently have genuinely been
decent human beings, which is
rare as defined in movies.
Is there a unique challenge to
playing someone who is just
fundamentally decent, who
is not dealing with more
dramatic--?
JOHN GALLAGHER: Yeah, I think
the challenge is to make sure
that that stays believable.
Because I think it's hard to
convince an audience that
there are saints in the
world nowadays.
It's like tough.
And especially in a small,
intimate movie that very much
is about real people, it
can be very easy to be
like, aw, come on.
He would have left the
relationship by now.
He would have been
out of there.
Or I don't know if people
are thinking that.
BRIE LARSON: They're like,
he's a pain in the ass.
Get him--!
JOHN GALLAGHER: Oh my god, I
can't believe he's so patient!
BRIE LARSON: He should be
running for the hills!
JOHN GALLAGHER: Because at a
certain point, I think that
can start to almost become
unrealistic in a way.
But Dustin took care of that
challenge for me by the
beautiful reveal in the last
half of the film that you
actually see that this person
is a grown up product of the
foster care system working
for someone.
And so you see why
that character is
selfless in that way.
Because he almost did not have
a family, and is with this
person that he knows
needs one.
And he wants to provide that.
And so that, in this case, made
it kind of easy to live
inside that.
And it just feels
good to be nice.
And I wish I was as selfless
and good as the
character in the film.
But Dustin created such a nice
atmosphere on set, and working
with those kids, it was not a
problem being nice to them
because they're just the best.
DAVID EHRLICH: And the last time
I spoke with Dustin, we
talked a little bit about how
Rami's character, Nate, was
sort of his proxy.
And I'm wondering, for you
guys, how much you saw of
Dustin in that character, if
Nate's innocence or whatnot,
if his sense of humor was--
how close it cleaved
to your director?
BRIE LARSON: I see a little bit
of Dustin in everybody in
it, just the tone of it and the
dry sense of humor and the
subtlety of it.
And the thing that I personally
just gained from
working with him was the
ability to be, and it's
something that I don't--
maybe people do say this
to you all the time.
And don't get a big
head about it.
But he's not trying
to prove anything.
He's very easy to be around,
and very nonjudgmental.
And I think the film is unbiased
and nonjudgmental.
DAVID EHRLICH: And I guess I'll
ask one more question
before we open it
up to the floor.
But there are some great bike
riding scenes in this movie.
And I think there's a long
tradition in the cinema of
bikes in movies.
But you are one of the great
bike riding actresses, I
think, proven in this film?
BRIE LARSON: Would you
agree with it?
I would think not.
I think there's some bike
riding that got cut out
because I wasn't very
good at it.
DUSTIN CRETTON: There were a few
that got cut out because
Brie wasn't very
good at going--
she was really good
at going downhill.
BRIE LARSON: I wasn't good
at going uphill.
But we found out later--
DUSTIN CRETTON: But
it was a bad bike.
BRIE LARSON: Yeah, it
was on a bad gear.
DUSTIN CRETTON: Always
blame the bike.
It was a bad bike.
BRIE LARSON: I'm pretty
in shape.
There's no--
I can ride a bike!
DUSTIN CRETTON: That's
not what I'm saying.
I think the seat was too low, so
then your knees were coming
up too high.
DAVID EHRLICH: But still,
it's very expressive.
I'm in your character's head
when you're on that bike.
So well done.
BRIE LARSON: Thanks!
DAVID EHRLICH: So does anyone
have any questions?
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So I have
a question about--
I guess my question
has two parts.
One, what was the casting
process like for the kids?
And then two, what
was the rehearsal
process like for everybody?
DUSTIN CRETTON: Do I need
to repeat the question?
So the question was about the
casting process for the kids,
and then the rehearsal process
for everybody.
The casting process for the kids
was fairly traditional in
that I sat in a room and
stressed out and freaked out
for three weeks thinking
how impossible this
task is going to be.
Because it was impossible.
It was very difficult to find
what we needed in the short
period of time that we had.
And by some miracle, in every
occasion on every single
character at some point,
somebody came in and did
something in that performance
that made me forget I had
written those lines, and made me
forget even that I was in a
little room watching
an audition.
And they moved me, made
me laugh, made me cry.
And there was always just one
miracle that walked in.
Kaitlyn Dever came in, and when
she left I was just--
I didn't even say bye, it was
a little awkward, because I
was just crying.
And her scene was also a
very emotional scene.
So we were both crying.
And then she just said, OK!
And then she said, OK, bye!
And she left.
And a version of that happened
with everybody.
And thank goodness that their
schedules worked out.
Because there was no option
two for any character.
So that's how the casting
process went.
The rehearsal process was less
about rehearsing scenes and
more about really getting to
know each other and build
relationships.
And we had one day.
And so we all got together.
And we had some food.
And then, we sat around
in a circle.
And I had my friend Kevin who
works at a place very similar
to this and has been doing it
for I think 15 years or so, he
came up and everyone was able
to ask him questions.
All the kids were able to tell
him about the characters they
were playing, and then explain
their back story.
And then he related to them
other stories that they could
pull from of real kids that he
knew and stories that he knew.
And then, John, we did our first
attempt at playing that
game big booty, which was
horrible, but really fun.
And I think what it did was
allowed all of our kids, it
allowed them to see John and
Brie be silly, and allowed
them to see that it's OK to be
silly, which is huge for this
film, and huge for I think
creating this environment that
is very safe and free.
So thank goodness for all those
things somehow lining up
in this small project with a
very short window of prep.
DAVID EHRLICH: A question that
I have to ask on behalf of
everyone I've spoken
to about the film.
Did you work at short
term number 12?
Or did you just like the
alliteration for the title?
Very important.
DUSTIN CRETTON: It's actually
not necessarily the name of
the place that I worked at.
But there was a short term 12 at
And there are short term
12's at other places.
It's fairly common.
There are short term facilities,
long term
facilities within
each group home.
And the number refers
to the level of care
that the kids need.
And so 14 is the highest--
in the system that I am familiar
with, 14 was the
highest, and 12 was the next
level down, and it keeps going
down from there.
So there's also a long term 12,
and a long term 14, and a
short term 14.
DAVID EHRLICH: I was also
wondering if you could talk a
little bit about the music.
In the movie, there's a
beautiful soundtrack.
And it sneaks up on you because
it's not especially
intrusive, but I think walking
away from the movie, you hear
it resonating in your head,
or at least I did.
So I'm curious as to how that
became part of the process,
how closely you worked
with the musician.
And when you were writing the
scripts, or when you were on
set, if you knew exactly
what tones you wanted
the score to have?
DUSTIN CRETTON: Joel P. West is
a friend of mine who I was
actually a fan of his music
before we became friends and
started working together.
And so he's just a wonderful
person to create stuff with.
And he came on set.
He didn't really start composing
until we began
editing, but he did come on set
a couple of times to feel
what it was like to be in the
room while we were shooting
some of these more
intimate scenes.
And I think he took that sense
of quiet back with him.
And the idea of having a score
trickle in as opposed to slap
you in the face was
something that we
wanted from the beginning.
And Joel, I think, just his
instincts are just he writes
really beautiful things that
I love listening to.
And I would love to put on
in my car and just--
his music has always been,
whether it's his band, The
Tree Ring that he plays in, or
scores that he's done with me,
his music has always put
pictures into my brain.
And so it's a really nice thing
to add into the movie.
DAVID EHRLICH: Do you still
listen to it independently?
Do you put on the vinyl?
DUSTIN CRETTON: Yeah, I do.
There's no vinyl yet.
But the soundtrack actually I
think is being released next
Tuesday or something.
You can find it on iTunes and
pre-order it and listen to
some of the tracks.
It's really beautiful.
DAVID EHRLICH: And have
you screened the
film for any kids?
I don't know what the
circumstances would be like,
but for more direct feedback?
DUSTIN CRETTON: You mean
kids in the system?
DAVID EHRLICH: Sure.
DUSTIN CRETTON: Yeah, we have
not taken the film to an
actual foster care facility
just because
it's a rated R movie.
But I've had on a number of
occasions at festivals, the
second festival we played at,
I had a kid come up to me.
He was 20.
And he said he was aged out of
the system two years earlier.
And he had been living in a
facility really similar to
this one his whole
teenage life.
And when he said that,
I was like, oh, crap.
Here comes the "you suck at
making movies" comments.
And he was just very thankful.
And he said he came in ready
to hate the movie.
And thank god that he was very
moved and touched and thankful
that we had done something
that at least represents
enough of his experience
that he was able to
identify with the movie.
So that was very
special for me.
DAVID EHRLICH: Well, I think
that's all the time we have.
But thank you guys so
much for coming and
talking about the film.
It's great.
BRIE LARSON: Thank you.
JOHN GALLAGHER: Thank you.
DAVID EHRLICH: It'll
be out next Friday.
So tell your friends,
go see it again.